all right many in the media are ignoring
this story but we are not
damning new details revealed just how
far new york disgraced governor andrew
cuomo
senior aides reportedly went to conceal
the number of nursing home deaths
during the pandemic the new york times
reports
that cuomo's office stopped health
officials
from publishing the real number of
nursing home data
for months more than a year ago our very
own janisteen lost both in-laws he was
befuddled obviously saddened
but knew they needed to get answers
after they developed covet 19
and then found out they went back to the
nursing home once they were positive for
this
knowing they had other options it was
like burnishing a furnace
putting gasoline on it janisteen joins
us now janice the new york times finds
documents
that the march directive that was
reversed in a couple of months later
was more damaging than anyone thought
they downplayed the number of deaths how
significant is this to the investigation
well you have to ask why did they
downplay those numbers for
so long and this is extensive
the extent that they went to make sure
that this was not
uncovered right and he would go on these
interviews on television when they would
finally ask him
the question about the nursing homes he
would give false information and he knew
all along he was lying so
why did he and his top aides including
melissa derosa
go to such great lengths to make sure
that no one would find out the real
total of the deaths i think it's because
it's criminal and he had a book to sell
a four million dollar
book so just for everyone to understand
because some other states did the same
thing march 25th cuomo issued the
initial directive instructing nursing
home
to accept their patients back uh in who
are positive for the virus instead of
staying out of the hospital or staying
out of the way or
going to the ship in may he realized
that's a problem apparently
and he reversed that he said six
thousand people lost their lives the
number was fifteen thousand
that was a democratic attorney general
that found out that
we're finding out now that he knew the
total all along
never answered questions at his daily
press conferences either
lied every single time if this is not
obstruction of justice i don't know what
is brian i feel like him
the governor and the people around him
that knew this
and tried to cover it up they need to go
to jail i don't think that's ever going
to happen but i
do want justice to happen on behalf of
the 15
000 dead family members so commissioner
howard zucker
listen i know you work for the governor
but what do you stand for
he was basically told to keep his mouth
shut he is the new york state health
official
so they said don't release this death
toll and he didn't
and when he's asked about it he skirts
it here's what cuomo's attorney says
the whole brouhaha here is overblown to
the point where there are cynical
suggestions offered for the plain and
simple truth
that the chamber wanted only to release
accurate information that they believed
was totally
unassailable that doesn't pass the laugh
or smell test
so the deaths of over fifteen thousand
elderly
is a brouhaha that's what the lawyer has
to say
i think our families deserve justice and
i hope it happens soon
our lawmakers and albany need to do
something this whitewash of an
impeachment is ridiculous
go in there today and get it done there
are at least four
investigations into this governor how
much more
do you need to get him out
janice and on a side note he was asked
about his accusers this week
he basically says their venal their
publicity hounds
and their liars and then he said yeah i
touched some people
but never inappropriately how the heck
he still has a job or every democrat
stands for the metoo movement
i will never understand i am i don't get
it but he seems to be selling out to the
left
so they don't turn on him and force him
out and that's where we're all getting
tax increases
and everything that we're seeing right
now uh janisteen thanks so much don't
give up
i want brian thank you you got it